well it's interesting how this how this
happens you know and this is he told us
I don't think I've told this particular
part of of oh good of how this works out
so it they didn't know to and to be fair
to the writers they they didn't know
where the role was going they sort of
went with it they knew where the show
was ending and where it was at beginning
it was going to start on Jack's eye and
then and on his eye and emotionally they
knew and and thematically they knew
everything else was movable parts and
which was what was amazing about the
show is that you know they it's like
what uh what Damon said is like you know
once they you know they hit the walls
they started like they're boxed in well
they started to climb up the walls and
so so they were so inventive and and the
show was so rich in that way and it was
amazing and my character benefited from
that so lo and behold it gets to a point
where you know it's I love guesting on
it I've been recurring on it now for a
season a bit but I need I need pilot I
need to get a pilot I need pilot money
if they're not going to commit to
anything you know I got to support the
family yeah my wife had just you know
essentially quit you know acting so I
was like it's on me now I got to get at
least a pilot fee if not a pilot that
goes to start paying for these schools
and you know you know just life and so I
was like well just you know and so I did
this pilot called or Kane for CBS
and J is about a Cuban family of sugar
you know uh in the sugar business in
Florida and uh with Jimmy Smits and
Hector Elizondo Rita Moreno it's a great
cast amazing cast and um but I was like
I hope this doesn't jeopardize my role
on Lost yeah because we asked we said
look I may do this pilot but if you guys
offer us something just even a six
minimum episode thing I won't do the
pilot because I want to preserve this on
lost because you know I mean I love the
role they wouldn't do that and they're
like we just don't know we can't so I
was like well you know I got to pay
bills man I gotta you know yeah and look
the cane was a great opportunity in and
of itself it was like these great casts
so I was like like and but I've got to
also feed the family so so I went I did
Kane I had a blast on Kane and then I go
back and then they call me back on lost
and I was like oh they need me now I
lost and then I I remember Landing in
Hawaii and I remember telling Jack
Bender I go don't kill me off do not
kill me off on the show I don't know
that this Pilot's gonna get picked up so
I please don't kill me off and he goes
what's it about he goes well it's about
this you know wealthy uh Cuban family
and you know that is in the rum business
and you know Florida goes it's about
rich people in Florida because that's
never going to go you know so yeah just
conceptually he's like that's not gonna
get picked up and sure enough he gets
picked up and they don't kill me off and
I'm like oh no no I mean I'm like now
wow I hope I didn't put the show in a
pickle but you know but not your fault
but it's now you know so not my fault so
sure enough you know but now I was like
I hope we're able to work around you
know and I did 13 episodes of Kane it
didn't go beyond that but as I'm doing
that I'm hoping I hope they bring me
back I'm lost and sure enough you know
Kane gets killed through the rider
strike and then and then lost does call
me back and I and I go great and then at
that point we're like hey can we do a
deal anything you know and they're like
we just don't know where the role is
going and they didn't know they didn't
know so very long story I you know
continued doing lost and then another
opportunity comes up and it's just a a
six episodes to test for Kath and Kim
you know to you know to play one and
therefore if you force their hand
inadvertently and and that's when they
made the deal those bastards but listen
it's just the way of the business I know
they're trying to save money they don't
want to make your regular it's like you
know and they don't they knew how an
integral you know I mean listen they
they do and they don't uh to be fair I I
don't you know when it's that and
there's a lot of characters that's what
I'm saying it's like yeah I know that's
true and if you get on the other side of
it as a producer you have to think look
it's not an unlimited budget you know
and and these things get inflated very
quickly and it's crazy where they start
cutting and they have to because they
have to justify it so I get the other
side of it you know yeah it's just the
business it's just it's just the nature
of it and until you learn leverage you
you don't know what you know what you
have and it's not uh you know there's no
animosity there it's just it's just
understanding how it works you know